es gibt fünf Fehler die so so viele
Hobbygärtner im Gemüsegarten machen und
deswegen schauen wir uns die alle mal an
damit ihr die in eurem Garten auf jeden
Fall vermeidet das Leben könnte
schließlich so viel leichter sein grabt
ihr eure Beete eigentlich noch um das
wäre nämlich in meinen Augen der
allererste Fehler weil es so so so viel
mehr Sinn ergibt ob das Umgraben zu
verzichten wenn wir uns mal anschauen
wie so ein Boden aufgebaut ist wenn man
da so ein Stück abschneiden würde und
von der Seite gucken würde dann würde
man sehen dass der Boden aus ganz vielen
unterschiedlichen Schichten besteht und
jede dieser Schichten hat auch eine ganz
eigene Funktion und vor allem Leben in
jeder dieser Schichten einfach auch
unterschiedliche Tierchen
Mikroorganismen wusstet ihr das in einer
Handvoll Gartenerde mehr Lebewesen
enthalten sind als Menschen auf diesem
Planeten wohnen und unser ganzes Leben
beruht auf deren Existenz ohne die
werden wir nicht das ist so unglaublich
und so viele Leute sehen das nicht die
laufen auf dem Boden rum und denken das
wäre direkt das ist unsere
Lebensgrundlage und deswegen ist es auch
so unfassbar wichtig dass man so hat
dass man auf die kleinen Kerlchen
aufpasst und das geht eben viel besser
wenn man seine Beete nicht umgräbt
kommen wir noch mal zurück zu unserem
Bodenschichten hier oben wohnen ja ganz
andere Tierchen als vielleicht hier
weiter unten wenn wir umgrabenen
Schichten wir aber die obere
Bodenschicht nach unten und die untere
nach oben und dann kann es sein dass
Lebewesen da unten ersticken das kann
sein dass sie keine Nahrung mehr
vorfinden wir Schaufeln sozusagen ein
Massengrab für das Bodenleben und das
muss aufhören und deswegen legt bitte
kompostbeete an das ist so so leicht
ohne Umgraben zu gärtnern man spart sich
selber so viel Arbeit man erntet so viel
mehr wenn man Kompost bete anlegt man
muss kaum noch jetzt weil nämlich im
natürlich gewachsenen Mutterboden ein
quasi unerschöpfliches Potenzial an
Unkrautsamen schlummert und einen
kleinen wurzelteilchen aus denen wieder
neue Wurzeln und Kräuter wachsen können
und wenn man das jedes Mal umgibt dann
holt man ja wieder neue Samen an die
Oberfläche die da wieder aufgeben können
und neue wurzelteilchen kommen nach oben
und natürlich wächst dann immer wieder
Neues Unkraut auch wenn man noch so viel
Geld das hört nicht auf wenn wir aber
kompostbeete anlegen und ohne
umgrabengärtnern dann kommen diese
wurzelteilchen und sahen nicht mehr an
die Oberfläche und so müssen wir als
Gärtner viel viel weniger jäten und Tun
unserem Garten noch was Gutes ich habe
einen mini-kurs zum Gemüse anbauen wo es
auch ganz viel um die kompostbeete geht
wo ich euch genau zeige wie man die
anlegt und was man dabei beachten muss
den verlinke ich euch einmal hier oben
und auch im angepinnten ersten Kommentar
damit ihr euch dafür anmelden könnt was
kostet euch 0 € und bringt euch so enorm
viel weiter in eurem Garten also schaute
auf jeden Fall rein eine andere Sache
mit den Bodenschichten ist dass der
Boden eines Struktur hat die dafür
ausgelegt ist Wasser zu speichern wenn
man den umgräbt da muss man gleichzeitig
auch viel mehr gießen wenn man
stattdessen Kompass bitte anlegt dann
speichert der Kompost Wasser so dass man
viel weniger gießen muss da kann man
noch mehr Techniken anwenden die zeige
ich euch alle im Bootcamp also meldet
euch dafür auf jeden Fall an ein anderer
Fehler den ganz ganz ganz viele Leute
machen die gerade erst mit dem Gärten
anfangen ich Pflanzen viel zu dicht zu
pflanzen weil wenn man da so ein Bild
vor sich hat und dann hat man so ein
kleines Samenkorn und aus dem soll
später mal einen Kohlkopf werden kann
man sich schwer vorstellen dass der
irgendwann mal so viel Platz braucht
Kohl kann richtig richtig groß werden
und viele andere Gemüse auch nee
Zucchini Pflanze braucht zum Beispiel
den ganzen Quadratmeter Platz nur für
sich deswegen achtet immer drauf wie
viel Platz die einzelnen Pflanzen
brauchen das sollte in der Regel hinten
auf dem Samen Tütchen mit drauf stehen
man legt oft viel hilft viel ich pack
einfach mein Bild so voll wie es nur
irgendwie geht damit ich auch ja ganz
ganz viel ernten kann aber das
resultiert am Ende eigentlich nur daran
dass man überhaupt nichts erntet weil
die einzelnen Pflanzen gar nicht den
Raum haben um groß zu werden und
überhaupt zu Ernte Reifen zu kommen also
achtet auf die Abstände auch wenn ihr
euch erstmal extrem groß vorkommen das
hat schon den Sinn die sind so
ausgeklügelt dass man das Optimum aus
seinen beten rausholt wenn man sich dran
hält fehler Nummer drei im ersten Jahr
Prinzessinnen anbauen es gibt ein paar
Gemüse mit denen haben sogar Profi
Gärtner und Gärtnerinnen zu kämpfen das
ist nicht so einfach auszubauen die sind
zwar sehr sehr lecker das sind zum
Beispiel der Blumenkohl und der Rotkohl
Rotkohl ist noch einfacher als
Blumenkohl aber Blumenkohl ist schon so
ein bisschen Königsdisziplin da braucht
man ein bisschen Erfahrung deswegen
würde ich allen die gerade erst anfangen
zu gärtnern diese Liste von Gemüsen
empfehlen weil die nämlich viel viel
leichter sind natürlich kann man auch
mal was neues ausprobieren oder andere
Gemüse anbauen aber warte zumindest mit
den Prinzessinnen vielleicht bis zum
zweiten Garten ja bisschen mehr
gartenerfahrung gesammelt habe kennt ihr
das dass eure Pflanzen so ein bisschen
sind wie eure Babys und dass ihr euch
einfach so richtig gut um die kümmern
wollt und deswegen geht ihr auch jeden
Abend mit der Gießkanne raus damit die
ja genug zu trinken haben ist eigentlich
richtig gut gemeint in der Theorie
geht's den Pflanzen so ja richtig
richtig gut das Problem ist nur dass die
Pflanzen so abhängig davon werden dass
wir immer Gießen weil die Pflanzen
entwickeln ihre Wurzeln da wo sie das
Wasser bekommen in dem Fall ist das eine
Gießkanne am Tag die ist durchdringt den
Boden nicht besonders tief das ist
ziemlich nah an der Oberfläche wenn es
dann mal richtig heiß wird haben die
Pflanzen ein Problem weil ihre ganzen
Wurzeln einfach oben an der Oberfläche
sind was viel schlauer ist ist einmal in
der Woche richtig zu gießen so dass der
Boden sich auch in tiefere Schichten
richtig schön vollsaugen kann und die
Pflanzen auch angespornt sind dem Wasser
hinterher zu wurzeln und nicht nur
oberflächlich Wurzeln und dann so super
empfindlich werden und abhängig davon
dass man ständig gießt so könnt ihr ja
dann auch gar nicht in Urlaub fahren
wenn ihr dann denkt huch meine Pflanzen
kann ich ja nicht zwei Wochen alleine
lassen wenn man gemüsebabys hat ist da
also schon auch ein bisschen Erziehung
nötig ich versuche so zu Gärtner dass
ich möglichst gar nicht mehr gießen muss
ich gieße vor allem noch die Gurken weil
die sonst bitter werden und ganz junge
Pflanzen die ich gerade gesät oder
gepflanzt habe aber darüber hinaus
versuche ich gar nicht mehr zu gießen
und das klappt sehr sehr gut dazu habe
ich auch ein Video in meinem
Gemüsegarten Bootcamp also schaut auf
jeden Fall vorbei das lohnt sich heute
mal so richtig dass man was Tomaten
angeht auch richtig viel falsch machen
kann und dazu habe ich auch schon mal
ein Video gemacht das findet ihr hier
drüben und ansonsten geht raus macht die
Welt ein bisschen Koordinaten und wir
sehen uns nächste Woche wieder